[Musique]
enfin la taxe avec antoine penot ce soir
antoine notre bon soir soit clair au
menu ce soir une un fox autour d'
emmanuel macron oui absolument clair en
pleine campagne présidentielle du second
tour les infos qu'ils ont le vent en
poupe c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
avec ce tweet notamment que je vous
affiche ici à l'écran avec une capture
d'écran vous le voyez c'est ça qui nous
intéresse en dessous relayé donc par ce
tweet que l'on présente comme celui du
média britannique bien connu de la bbc
on y voit donc la charte graphique du
média du média britannique avec cette
photo du président candidat avec ce qui
est présenté comme une station que je
vous livre l'europe devra accepter
jusqu'à 60 millions de réfugiés au cours
des 20 prochaines années en provenance
d'afrique du moyen-orient car les
sanctions économiques en contre la
russie entraînant un effondrement
économique de en afrique fin de citation
un une soi-disant déclaration qui a
également beaucoup circulé sur facebook
vous en montre ici un exemple cet
utilisateur lui vous le voyez le
présente même comme une promesse de
campagne du président candidat à rien
que ça elles n'ont pas de le critiquer
vous le voyez y aura les deux questions
qui se posent clair c'est ce tweet
existe-t-il petit 1 et at il vraiment le
président dit cette phrase on va
commencer par tenter bien de retrouver
l'origine de ce tweet tweet on voit
qu'il doit killed qu'il daterait domaine
de le tweet d'origine du 11 avril ici
c'est ce qu'on voit tout en bas du tweet
alors donc on ici info ou intox on
allait voir sur le site de la bbc s'il
est bien un tweet et intel tweet
existait la date du 2 avril et viendront
ceux qu'on retrouve en revanche c'est
cette courte vidéo qui effectivement
traite de la campagne présidence et la
bbc qui se posait cette question est ce
que marine le pen peut gagner l'élection
présidentielle rien à voir donc avec le
tweet sur emmanuel macron vous l'avez
compris la photo elle en revanche
provient bien également d'un autre tweet
vous l'apercevez de la bbc là encore de
la même date du 11 avril on s'aperçoit
donc qu'il s'agit très vraisemblablement
d'un montage et que ce tweet n'a donc
jamais été publiée par la bbc ici info
ou intox on est même allé plus et aux
observateurs d'ailleurs nos confrères
ont d'ailleurs contacté la bbc le
journaliste les b les journalistes de la
bbc
n'ont jamais eu ce tweet et olga
robinson qui est donc journalistes à la
bible une précise que ce schéma de
diffusion d'un fox est similaire à
d'autres infos qu'il vient souvent de
comptes télégramme russe relayant
notamment la version du kremlin sur la
guerre en ukraine et olga robinson qui
est la personne que nous avons
interrogés qui travaille donc à la bbc a
bien raison car effectivement on
retrouve l'origine de ce faux tweets sur
une chaîne télégramme que je vous montre
ici elle s'appelle intent intel slavia z
on a déjà une idée de son contenu vous
vous en doutez bien elle se présente
comme un agrégateur je cite deux
nouvelles rues ce qui couvre le monde
entier rien que ça voilà donc pour la
première trace de ce tweet sur un compte
pro russes donc vous l'avez compris un
faux tweets donc ça c'est pour la forme
mais sur le fond emmanuel macron at il
affirmé que 60 millions de réfugiés al
est arrivé en europe d'abord oui c'est
toute la question est bien en apparence
non en tapant ses déclarations dans
plusieurs moteurs de recherche en trombe
jamais sur cette information ni sur
cette citation la retrouve simplement
mentionné dans ce tweet si que j'ai donc
retrouvé pour vous qui fait donc qui
date du 17 avril sur la position des
manuels mac on savait que ça nous
intéresse sur l'immigration en revanche
rien de fait référence à ces fameux 60
millions de réfugiés dans son programme
le président le président sortant
affirme vouloir que la france prenne sa
part c'est un petit peu plus loin dans
nos articles dans cet article du monde
de nos confrères que j'ai retrouvé pour
vous que la france je cite prenne sa
part dans l'accueil des réfugiés sans
donner aucun chiffre ces dernières
semaines il a d'ailleurs affirmé le
président candidat vouloir défendre un
mécanisme de solidarité à la carte mais
là encore sans donner de détails donc
alors antoine on va pas ce qui t'es là
dessus vous vouliez nous parler d'une
autre un fox autour d'un candidat
malheureux à l'élection présidentielle
il s'agit de gens mélangent oui
absolument rapidement aller autour d'une
information détournez vous allez le
comprendre sur les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs publications on les apercevait
ont relayé des photos de cet ancien
article d'une interview dont deux du
leader de la france insoumise avec ce
chapeau qu'on voit au titre de l'article
le seul parti qui réhabilite la
politique c'est le front national
sous-entendu une forme de soutien de
jean luc mélanchon front national
l'article i provient d'un journal qui
malheureusement n'existe plus et est le
quotidien de paris ce dernier a en effet
fermé ses portes c'était en
196 en revanche on retrouve bien trace
de cette déclaration de sursis le site
internet une fois de plus de nos
confrères du monde avec la bonne date
vous l'apercevez juste ici le 26
décembre 1991 lorsqu'il ne dit pas ce
tweet original et bien qu'issue danton
qui est bien que jean luc mélenchon
soutient le front national est bien
c'est l'intégralité de la citation que
j'ai retrouvé pour vous je vous la livre
le pays est assis sur une poudrière de
gens qui ne se porte plus la situation
actuelle ces gens là veulent du
changement mais nous proposons toujours
rien alors ils vont voir ailleurs le ps
à abandonner la politique je vais vous
le dire quelque chose d'affreux
aujourd'hui le parti qui réhabilite la
politique eh bien c'est le front
national des propos on le voit bien
qu'ils sont bien loin du soutien au fn
vous l'avez compris est plutôt une
critique de ce dernier surtout du ps en
filigrane à noter que c'est un fox et
bien ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'elle ressort elle avait déjà été
opposé à jean luc mélenchon lors d'une
autre élection présidentielle c'était en
2012 le candidat s'en est d'ailleurs
expliqué dans cette émission présentée à
l'époque par valérie trierweiler sur la
chaîne des huit merci beaucoup antoine
fenoyl on peut retrouver votre chronique
sur notre site internet
www.francebillet.com on se retrouve dans
quelques instants rester avec nous